um let's talk about someone I consider
to be a madman Alex Jones uh Alex Jones
has made it to the big league ladies and
gentlemen he has his own attack ad from
a pro Hillary Clinton super PAC roll the
footage for me this is Alex Joel not let
you down you'll be very very impressed i
hope and i think we'll be speaking a lot
Sandy Hook is a synthetic completely
fake with actors in my view manufactured
I will not let you down the official
story is affable and an inside job is
the only explanation you will be very
very impressed I hope they're the ones
running Isis I mean I've interviewed the
cops and then and the people that saw
the feds plant the bombs Oklahoma City I
think we'll be speaking a lot nothing
she's gonna show up and on drugs though
[ __ ] I will not let you down she's a
freaking demon and she stinks and so
does Obama ago like what sulfur I have
the government documents where they said
they're gonna encourage homosexuality
with chemicals so that people don't have
children like a button chemicals in the
water they turn the friggin frogs gang
I'll tell ya it is sure real man um wow
I don't know what to say about that
other than he's very successful great he
has a he has a thriving youtube channel
so congratulations on that but i don't
know if that's an indictment against
america or is that an indictment against
people who are on youtube i mean i mean
i i'm on youtube so i benefit from it as
well but man do you think this is um it
is this elevating alex jones to a level
that he should not be elevated to or is
this just a way of alarming people to
say this is a type of insanity the
Donald Trump buys into well it's
interesting because alex jones his
viewpoints really don't line up too well
with Trump's and just when Trump was
becoming popular and it seemed like he
was going to win the Republican
nomination that's when he kind of
boarded the Trump train so to speak yeah
and so I mean it's it's interesting that
Trump is able to give credence to the
things that that Alex Jones is say
when really this guy deserves no
attention from any major presidential
candidate whatsoever with the conspiracy
theories and the the harmful things that
he said I means Sandy Hook like I mean
that's not a laughing matter right that
does a extremely tragic situation he he
goes into the the propaganda of being a
flaw false flag to get people's guns
right and it was all staged 911 thinks
it was a good well I won't even talk
about that because then we might get
attacked by a lot of people who believe
that it was an inside job but you know
it's it really I agree with you he
should not be elevated to the level of
any national prominence especially from
a presidential candidate but Donald
Trump has brought this entire group of
Americans into the from the dredges of
society into the limelight so what do
you do with it now do we do we warn
people and say this is a type of sanity
or do we just keep ignoring it when this
is really you know you have Alex Jones
you have Paul Jones whatever I forgot
his middle name from YouTube you have
Breitbart you have all these outlets
that are extreme right all right who are
supporting Donald Trump fueling his rise
do we just ignore them and of course to
Steve Bannon and Roger Ailes your major
players in his campaign and it really
probably goes to the fact that once he
loses if he noses he's probably gonna
create this big media empire and call it
Trump TV yeah and I mean what better to
go on Trump TV he's not going to get the
bill o'reilly right he's not going to
get um you know the the megyn kelly ever
right but he can definitely get someone
like sean hannity he can get Tommy
Lauren of the blaze he can get anyone
from Breitbart to be a part of this
media empire so he can get Alex Jones
right Alex Jones would love to be on
Trump TV a nationally syndicated
nationwide cable access program whatever
you want to call it Alex Jones would
love to be there and Donald Trump is the
the the just the right conduit to bring
this type of insanity to the national
stage in a way that it's never been well
in my recent memory has it ever been on
the national stage so listen folks it's
been a pleasure sitting in with you
today David will be back tomorrow Pat
it's been a pleasure man you have a
really great take on a lot of things man
thanks for joining the conversation with
me absolutely and i'll be sure to watch
more on the benjamin dixon show ya folks
i do that follow me subscribe to the
channel I'm sure Dave would wouldn't
mind dropping the link in the
description to my channel also you can
follow me over at the BPD show on
twitter we are lit over there you may
not want to follow me if you don't like
controversial things so if you do like
controversial things and good
conversations come over there on twitter
or go to the benjamin dixon show com i
am not like alex jones i tried to appeal
to reason and logic maybe that's why i
only have a handful of subscribers on
youtube but to thine own self be true
pat it's been a pleasure Dave I'll see
when you get back and you all have a
great rest of your day